and how good is stamp fair taex and the
story lean up to us when they post
Angela Lee retiring God and when she had
to go tell stamp she's like hey this is
going to be for the legit belt yeah oh
my God and stamp's like I'm going to try
my best I'm GNA try my best and I keep
telling you guys this if you get a
chance to watch stamp Fair TX you think
she's just big you know in the Asian
market she is a bonafied superstar out
here I don't care what organization
you're talking about it'd be tough to
find someone bigger than damp Fair Tex
and also skill-wise oh again to compare
it to these other leagues you know they
might have some wrestling background
they might be a Jiu-Jitsu gold medalist
something like that but stamps
credentials filthy in her walkout she's
just a unique character man she's such a
bad they they got a superstar there they
got a straight up Superstar